you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast eliza first principle
presented at the Abscam virtual
addition support and products to advance
your research virtual event and
presented by dr. Ralph Paul a scientific
support manager at ab cam
I am Suzy Valdez of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by ab cam for more
information about our sponsor visit WWF
GM calm before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appear on the
screen well answer as many questions
that we've had time for at the end of
the presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or just use
that ask a question box to let us know
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
click on the accreditation button
located at the promotional board at the
bottom Center and follow the process to
obtain your credits please join me now
in welcoming our presenter dr. Ralph
Paul I'll now turn the presentation over
to him welcome sir Thank You Susie thank
you for that introduction
and thank you to all the viewers out
there today for taking your time and
joining me for this introduction and
review of the iliza technique and
discussion of some common questions and
issues that arise when eliza's are being
used by researchers
the overview of the webinar today will
be I will be talking about general
principles that apply to all types of
Eliza's and then describing the Verret
some variants of this technique
including the direct the competitive the
sandwich the simple step Eliza which is
a variation of the sandwich and then a
discussion of what could go wrong and
what kind of troubleshooting or
observations you might make if there are
in fact issues in the running of the
Eliza
so Eliza which is an acronym for
enzyme-linked immunosorbent assay was
first described by Engle and Perlman in
Stockholm and independently by snores
and women from the Netherlands with both
groups publishing in 1971 clear
immediate advantage of this general
technique is it does not rely upon the
use of radio isotopes and all of the
shipping handling and disposal issues
that Radio isotopes present to
laboratories variations of this
technique have been developed over time
and a wide variety of variants now exist
to analyze numerous analytes and in a
very robust sensitive rapid and high
throughput manner the term analyte will
be used throughout the presentation and
can be used to cover the wide variety of
target molecules that can be measured in
analyzer assay these targets can include
small organic molecules hormones and of
course very commonly proteins Elisha's
can be adapted such as the target
analytes can be measured when present in
a wide variety of matrices allowing for
substantial flexibility in sample
collection and type typical matrices are
described here plasma and serum saliva
urine milk cell culture media cell
lysate and tissue extracts of various
types it is important when considering
the type of matrix that you are looking
at to try to match the Eliza kit
specifically for that matrix one can
find a numerous Eliza kits for specific
targets that have been designed to be
used with a specific type of sample and
it's important to match those as
carefully as possible if possible
I will start today when talking about
the discussion and looking at the color
development part of the assay which will
be common to all of the variants that
I'll be discussing subsequently the
color development steps I'll rely upon
an analyte being immobilized in a well
that you can see in the diagram here and
then being able to develop a color based
off of the amount of the analyte present
and it will be trapped in various ways
on the bottom of a plate a very typical
format is a 96-well format that's
diagrammed here but there are numerous
assays that have been developed for much
higher plate numbers including 384 and
higher as well as different types of
holding vessels that can be measured by
a spectrophotometer and in all of the
formats there are also blocking agents
present at the bottom of the well
surface to prevent nonspecific binding
of the HRP bearing antibody or moiety
these blocking agents can include
detergents bovine serum albumin nonfat
dry milk whole serum and fish gelatin
and these blocking agents can be
specifically matched to the type of
matrices or analyte that is being
measured in the specific eliza assay
using a multiple format allows for
numerous samples to be analyzed
simultaneously and compared within the
same assay in many eliza kits the plates
can also be separated into individual
columns so that the entire plate doesn't
need to be used up in a single run this
allows a researcher to come back and run
additional samples later once they have
collected those samples we do however
strongly recommend that each time a
sample is run a standard curve is run in
parallel on the day of that assay it can
be difficult sometimes to compare OD
values from standards run on different
days an interpolation of data for
unknown samples can be erroneous
therefore it is strongly recommended
that a standard be generated each and
every time
after incubation with the HRP conjugate
and washing the solution of three three
prime five five prime tetramethyl
benzidine solution also known as TM B
for short is added to the plate over
time a blue color develops as a result
of the TB acting is a hydrogen donor for
the reduction of hydrogen peroxide to
water by the action of the HRP enzyme
this color intensity will be
proportionate to the quantity of HRP
present in a specific well in this
example on the Left we can see standard
controlled Aleutians in the left two
columns a save as duplicates also a
strong recommendation at least if trip
notes not triplicates in the other wells
we see varying amounts of analyte
present also assayed and duplicates and
although protocol booklets will
typically give you a standard incubation
time for color development it is also
prudent to observe the assay as the
color development continues and stop it
if it looks like some samples may be
getting saturated or multiple
concentrations of the standard curve may
be in danger of also saturating their
signal one of the ways to avoid any
issues with this is to do kinetic
measurements at OD 650 at multiple time
points and if there's any danger of
getting to saturation the dead last data
set that was collected where you get a
nice strong signal with a linearity of
the standard curve can be used as the
final time point alternatively the
typical experiment utilizes a quenching
reaction and in this case the quenching
solution is 0.16 molar sulfuric acid
solution which inhibits the enzyme and
stops it function and at this point the
assays is held in the state of color
development although it's now in a
yellow color and this can be read at OD
450 nanometers this is an endpoint
analysis the color will no longer
develop and then you can get your final
data from that and you can see what that
would look like on the left-hand side so
this has taken us through the color
development process which will be
identical for each of the particular
assays mentioned below and when we go
into the details there
our other assays that have been
developed using for instance alkaline
phosphatase but the HRP enzyme reaction
is by far the most commonly used for
various eliza's
in the direct iliza format the analyte
itself is directly bound to the plate
wells and a single antibody is used to
detect the analyte and this antibody
will have been conjugated to HRP already
it is the simplest of Eliza formats and
requires but a single antibody and what
would be an example of where this kind
of analysis might be used
in an illustration of a direct Eliezer
being used we can see data generated
which was used to characterize an
anti-human Kappa light chain antibody in
this particular experiment a constant
amount of IgG analyte was immobilized on
the plate and then there is a direct
correlation showing increased OD
measured as a concentration of the
conjugated antibody that is being
analyzed here is increased what's
important to notice here too is that it
indicates the specificity as when there
is a lambda light chain antibodies
immobilized on the plate there is no
signal observed or very little at the
high concentration this indicates the
specificity of the cap antibody has been
demonstrated with an immobilized analyte
on the plate this is a version of a
direct Eliza there are other formats
which can be set up like this as well
and there are other reasons what why
somebody might use this kind of approach
it can be used as we saw in the
illustration for antibody screening and
characterization I can also be used if
one is developing expression constructs
for recombinant proteins and wishes to
look at the various levels of expression
in the various constructs or growth
conditions of the cells or bacteria for
instance and if it's an acid that's very
used very commonly in a lab it is a nice
way to go if you can only need to run it
with one particular antibody and you can
perhaps pre make plates in advance of
running it the pro here is there's only
one antibody necessary it eliminates any
issues that might be related to the
presence of a second antibody and it
requires fewer steps to run issues might
be if there's any problem of conjugating
the antibody to the HRP and binding
activity is lost there is only one
antibody that you are in use and you may
have to transition to a different
antibody to try direct antigen
immobilization on the plate can
sometimes represent a problem area as
well in that you might result in higher
background levels due to nonspecific
material being bound and therefore a
simple antigen preparation is preparer
preferred such as a purified protein or
semi purified protein in the case of
looking at a recombinant expression
construct
and this may take additional steps in
time to accomplish and the other the
other issues that with a single antibody
eating being used one may wish to have
some flexibility and assay development
that is more inherent in a two antibody
system like sandwich Eliza where you can
look at finding different parts of the
protein of interest and define a larger
or a pro protein from a fragment
the next example will show here is a
competitive Eliza and in this case the
analyte present is binding to a capture
antibody that is on a plate and then you
come back with binding of a kit supplied
HRP conjugated analyte so you have the
same analytes that's being measured is
now also found as an HIV conjugate in
the kit and this presents a competitive
situation so therefore the greater
amount of sample analyte that was in the
sample you applied initially the greater
is the competition effect with the HRP
conjugated version of that same analyte
what this results in is a standard curve
that actually will go downwards that is
the higher the concentration of the
analyte present the more competition
there will be and the lower the signal
will become the type of analyte that is
very commonly measured in an assay like
this are small molecules or steroids
because they are not large enough
necessarily to accommodate the binding
of two antibodies in a sandwich type
Eliza and it can be difficult to raise
antibodies to some of those type of
targets a good example of this here is a
competitive Eliza this has been
developed for the analysis of cortisol
which is a stress response hormone and
as you can see in the standard curve as
you go to higher concentrations the OD
value goes down
in this type of format it's very
commonly used for small molecules and
you can also look at now in this case
starting to because you can pull the
analyte away from its surrounding matrix
that you can use a number of different
matrices that will more cleanly wash and
yield a signal therefore more complex
samples can be done again you only need
to have one antibody for this it's less
sensitive to the matrix effect then for
instance sandwich Eliza's because you
can more cleanly pull the analyte out
and you also develop good
reproducibility however not all analytes
are amenable to this format especially
very small molecules sometimes are not
very good as immunogen's therefore it
can be difficult to generate very good
antibodies to it and for the small kinds
of molecules that I described here it
can be much more sensitive than a
sandwich iliza and much more viable as
an approach the most commonly known of
iliza formats the sandwich
iliza requires multiple antibodies in
the end binding to the analyte and here
we see the various components the
capture and detector antibody the
detector most commonly associated with a
horseradish peroxidase this can be a
direct conjugation or through something
like a streptavidin biotin Association
as well and in this format as you can
see the more analyte that's bound to the
immobilizing capture antibody on the
bottom of the plate the higher the
signal will ultimately be and you have a
positive correlation with OD and typical
data is illustrated in the next slide
where you see in an Eliza setup for
human proxy for dachshund and you see
the very nice dynamic range in the
nanogram per mil levels and the standard
curve that's generated with the control
provided in the kit these simpie
sandwich Eliza does allow you a lot of
flexibility in choosing while where you
would like the antibodies to bind that
are responsible for a capture and
detection it can also allow you to look
at these analytes and various types of
matrices the sensitivity and specificity
now that you're using two
antibodies can be tremendous as
particularly the specificity aspect it
does require you to get a very nicely
matched pair of antibodies that will not
inhibit one another
I know internally this is something we
spend a lot of time working on is trying
to ensure that we get the sensitivity
and specificity you want with at the end
with antibodies that will not interfere
with each other's binding and it also
requires therefore that your analyte is
sufficiently large and accommodating
enough to have two or more of such
binding sites so that you can get clear
recognition in the sandwich itself so
now I'm going to talk about a relatively
new development in Sandwich eliza's that
is currently simple step iliza that by
adding yet another antibody makes the
whole process much more efficient and
quicker to use and it's a three-step
process and you will have your Eliza
result in 90 minutes post sample prep if
sample prep takes you an hour so then
you're looking at two and a half hours
for running the entire Eliza s a much
more rapid than the standard type of
sandwich Eliza in this sandwich Eliza
the capture antibody at the bottom of
the plate is specific to a tag and this
tag is now found on the capture antibody
for the analyte so you add the capture
antibody the analyte matrix itself and
the detector antibody conjugated to HR P
these are all mixed simultaneously
together in a single step incubation and
the anti tagged antibody pulls out the
entire complex the rest is washed off
and the teller development takes place
therefore you get a very rapid and
sensitive assay being developed with
very few issues being found in our
experience in talking to researchers
that are using these particular assays
this is a representative set of data you
for a human PDL one and you can see here
a very nice dynamic range with high
sensitivity and specificity the assays
are always developed with that in mind
to be as good as or better than any
other Eliza currently available for this
particular
target of interest the pros and cons are
really very much the same as they are
for the the sandwich Eliza itself being
a variant of it and particularly a nice
four researchers are is the fact that
you can run one of these in the morning
and have your data to look at and
perhaps talk to us about in scientific
support a tab cam or be able to display
in a presentation later that day so in
terms of resources as to what could go
wrong or where you might find answers or
more points that might point you in the
right direction especially if you're not
just buying analyze a kit but perhaps
developing analyze if I scratch is if
you will Google AB kam Eliza information
you will be taken to a landing page that
has a resource resources a that will go
take you through how to how to run
certain kits what kind of considerations
to have when looking into designing an
Eliza and what are kind of some of the
problems that you may encounter
perhaps devising analyzer yourself for
further information we encourage you to
contact one of our scientific support
teams across the globe and you can find
the contact information here and we are
happy to talk to you about either one of
our kits that you might be using or
issues that you might be encountering
with that or if you're just trying to
design a very specific and unique Eliza
for your own work we can try to help you
pick appropriate reagents and set up
appropriate controls for your assay
what kind of things could perhaps happen
is what are some of the questions we
will typically get and talk to people
about it do you have a good positive
control do you have a known positive
control sample a biologic that has been
in some other assays shown to have a
good level of the analyte you're
interested in or perhaps you have a
recombinant protein or purified analyte
that is separate from that provide as a
standard in the kit that's always a nice
way to make sure that you're properly
picking up a signal and the other
conversation that we get into is people
running assays and finding that they
don't get a sample giving a signal and
often there the discussion revolves
around the nature of the analyte for
something like the cortisol analyte that
I discussed earlier that's a stress
response hormone and each sample may not
have a very high signal or any at all
depending on the level of stress that
particular patient may have seen
resulting in expression or release of
that hormone so it is good to have some
idea of what to expect given the type of
sample you're looking at and then is
this Sam analyte going to be present in
within the range of the quoted
sensitivity for the assay do you need
something maybe more sensitive or
perhaps something a little less
sensitive so you don't have issues with
running the assay itself
concludes my set presentation and I am
now open for questions
thank you dr. Paul for that informative
presentation we will now start our lives
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on that ask a
question drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type that question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started let's take a look at our
audience member questions at this time
our first question dr. Paul is the
standard curve I generated is not
exactly like the one in the protocol
booklet is that okay we this is a
question we answer quite frequently
because of course people would like
their standard control data to look just
like we show in our sample illustrations
in the protocol booklets and this is not
necessary for to get a very usable a say
the exact OD values can be shifted
depending on how long the sample is
incubated the temperature that the
incubation is ran at we find in our labs
that just a couple of degrees of
difference can really affect the HRP
activity and the saturation level of the
particular standard curve and in
addition one might be using a different
spectrophotometer to get the readout as
compared to the one that we used in the
lab to generate the data in the protocol
booklet so as long as you have a very
nice correlation coefficient across the
data points the you do have a good dose
responsiveness that is at lower
concentrations the OD is lower and at
higher concentrations it moves up in a
predicted manner based on the dilution
that was used in the concentration of
the standard analyte present you should
be fine
interpolating data from such a standard
curve and get reliable data from it
thank you and I want to thank our
audience members for their incoming
questions our next question is a more
related question our audience member
wants to know my standard curve is fine
however my samples are failing to give a
signal can you help me understand that a
bit right so this is not again not an
uncommon issue that arises so the
standard curve is working so that tells
you that the assay is functional in your
hands and that the appropriate delusions
have been made and that the enzyme
reactions are all working at well so the
standard curve is fine the the samples
however sample prep is one of the
biggest issues that we discuss with
people in talking about Eliza's and one
of them is always can I prep samples and
let them be stored for a while or I did
store my samples for a while it's always
good to take a really good look at the
recommendations for a given kit we will
often recommend fresh samples be used
prepared that day or earlier that
earlier that day if possible is close to
the time of running of the assay will
sometimes give recommendations that if
you're going to stop prep to stop at a
certain point freeze the samples at a
very specific temperature be that minus
20 or minus 80 and the other thing I
always recommend to people if they do
have samples that have been stored where
there may have been some degradation is
to prepare at least one fresh sample at
the time of running the assay so you can
compare and contrast that one to the
ones that have for instance been stored
another reason for this kind of effect
is that the matrix in which your sample
is being measured is also an issue that
it's not may not be that well compatible
with the particular kit that you are
using so that is that that is an issue
that comes up quite frequently as well
people may wish to be looking at a
plasma sample and it turns out that the
kit that they have in hand was directed
towards samples that are tissue lysate
and those will often use quite different
blocking protocols and solutions to give
the signal so those are very common
effects that are observed but making a
fresh sample if your
dealing with samples that have been in
anyway stored for any period of time is
always a way to see if the assay is
working but may not be picking up the
your analyte in samples that have been
stored for some period of time
wonderful thank you we have a final
question and I want to remind audience
members that any question is not
answered today will be answered via
email our last question is my samples
are giving a uniformly high signal can
you help me understand that as well
right so this is kind of the inverse of
the previous problem where you can have
saturation of signal by your samples and
if for instance this is a an analyte
that is present at some abundance in all
of the samples you're looking at it may
be that you're simply saturating the
this the system and what you need to do
is make some delusions of the sample
before trying to interpolate data off of
the standard curve typically we will
recommend also in a situation where it's
an analyte that might be found at
constitutively high levels in the matrix
you're trying to analyze is to perhaps
start with a smaller experiment to look
at a dilution series of two ten
hundredfold dilution and see if those
any one of those will fall nicely within
the uniform part or linear part of your
standard curve in many of the protocols
we will give recommendations as to
delusions that might be used or
concentrations that have been found in a
very standard set of samples and from
those concentrations that have been
interpolated and the sensitivity of the
standard curve generated by the kit you
can make some calculations about the
dilution you may require to get your
sample to fall within the standard curve
thank you and thank you dr. Paul for
your presentation
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience today yep sure
the the Eliza assay is very commonly
used type of assay the variants give you
a number of different possibilities I
buy farm away haven't discussed all the
nuances that may be play a role in the
data that you're generating or if you
have some very specific
Eliza requests based on a novel approach
you might be using that may use
principles of Eliza even though your
assay wouldn't specifically be described
as that I would you encourage you to
contact this epicyte in the scientific
support group and we're happy to talk to
you directly or bring it to the
consideration of our RDP folks to help
you sort some of those questions out and
perhaps give you some guidance for your
work thank you for your time and thank
you to dr. Paul for your presentation
and for your important research I'd also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
AB camp for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
remind all audience members that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April of 2018 you'll
receive an email from labyrinth letting
you know that this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye
you